para crecer era un científico como hemos
venido sabiendo en las últimas horas tal
vez uno de los científicos más
importantes de irán también era un
guardia revolucionario como lo
confirmaron hoy y este hombre tenía a
cargo parte del programa nuclear iraní
lo que sucede es que tanto eeuu como
israel lo acusan de haber estado a cargo
de la investigación de un posible
proyecto de armas nucleares que irán
siempre ha negado a pesar de que se dice
que ese programa de investigación se
terminó en el 2003 también lo señalan de
haber estado investigando proyectos que
estaban totalmente subterráneos irán
como vuelvo a decir ha negado
absolutamente pero sí hemos sabido de la
importancia de este hombre que tenía a
su cargo toda la investigación del
ministerio de defensa no solamente en el
proyecto nuclear sino en otro tipo tipo
de armas y también como lo dijo el
presidente de hasan rohan y hoy también
investigaba sobre el cob y estaba a
cargo de la vacuna el proyecto que
investiga la vacuna y los kits de
atención rápida